I came across some hilarious video of
Jordan Peterson talking to Donald Trump
jr. his girlfriend a fox news host
kimberly guilfoyle and outrageous
right-wing darling charlie kirk and i
love this because it shows what happens
when different types of right-wingers
collide i can't put into words how
hilarious and bewildering the video i'm
about to play for you is so i'm going to
show you pieces of it and what you're
going to see here is that some kind of
event where i think this is the same
event where peterson appeared with
former trump advisor sebastian Gorka of
course peterson claims that he doesn't
really do political stuff but he's
appearing with sebastian Gorka behind
the scenes peterson is talking to Donald
Trump jr. and kimberly guilfoyle and
charlie Kirk and when I say that he's
talking to them it's accurate because
they don't say anything and they seem
totally confused about Peterson's
verbose carrying on this is a roughly
three and a half minute video I'm not
going to subject you to the entire thing
you'll notice in the video that the
three right-wing Stooges Trump jr.
guilfoyle and Kirk look totally
perplexed by what Peterson is talking
about and Peterson just goes on and on
and on and on so let's start with a tiny
bit of it and if you're listening and
not watching you might not notice that
there are other people in this
conversation it's not just a monologue
because nobody else speaks watch when
the camera pans to Trump jr. and
guilfoyle and Kirk the looks on their
faces are just stunning I was in
Washington a week ago and I was thinking
we're talking about how to bring people
together across the house divided
because the house is extraordinarily
divided now and people aren't talking
and I thought it would be very
interesting abortion is obviously key
issue but it's one that's unbelievably
contentious one of the things I thought
about with regards to the abortion issue
is that it's by the time you're talking
about abortion you're probably having
the wrong conversation which is why it's
so deeply polarized right
what's amazing about this is this is the
beginning of Peterson's answer to Donald
Trump jr. asking him hey Jordan how you
doing today so it continues and I'm kind
of skipping ahead a little bit the
others still have not spoken okay you
see the camera pan again to the three of
them they look like they've been
cornered at a cocktail party by the guy
who just won't stop talking about his
bird-watching hobby or how he's now
switching to sugar free diets or
whatever uh or in Jordan Peterson's case
how he once had apple cider vinegar and
it put him out for for a month or
whatever it was just continue to watch
the fact that they still have not spoken
the sexual taboos are very common across
cultures but you're seeing the same
thing you merge on the left in a
completely different form because on the
one hand especially the radical leftist
types their basic claim is that anything
goes right but but at the same time
they're putting forward these
affirmative consent regulations great
meeting of the minds there charlie Kirk
just looks physically exhausted by this
brutal beatdown with words and then it
just keeps going and going and going
they're upset on the left and they're
upset on the right so it would be well
so that's one of the things I thought of
myself I might discuss today I think
that would be yeah it's how to
encapsulate I mean in its party but I
think it's partly also a consequence of
the fact that we haven't adapted to the
bill birth control pill yet no one can
think of anything to say other than
Charlie Kirk saying that would be
powerful and then it's sort of seemed
like Peterson was winding down but
Charlie Kirk saying anything wound him
back up again and then we get to this
last part this is by the way I'm
skipping forward another minute of just
Jordan Peterson talking to them and
you'll see the camera show the other
three they look confused
they look punch-drunk they look like
they've been taking hits to the face for
12 rounds in a boxing ring take a look
that should be socially the leftist
types of especially in the 60s thought
it could just blow some sexual morality
apart completely because now people were
free to do what they want that isn't
working there's a there's a backlash
against that on the left as well so so
it would be well it would be fun and
necessary to think fun it would be
engaging and necessary to think that
because maybe there's some room for a
real discussion about that so I want a
lot of your speech say to be questions
if you can cuz this song mean this
audience would love much of it
70% alright so how long do you want me
to talk I think we have you slated for
quite a long time I just I just love it
charlie Kirk after seeing Jordan
Peterson Pat rant on and on about
nothing for three and a half minutes
gets the idea that you know we maybe we
should tell him to just mostly ask
questions during his speech instead of
doing this stuff every element of this
video is absolute gold well did you know
that social awkwardness and unhinged
unwanted cultural commentary are two of
jordan Peterson's twelve rules for life
yeah that's the thing that for someone
who is a psychologist and is helping
people better relate to others and is
giving advice this is exactly that type
of strange social behavior where if
you're at a dinner party with twelve
people and the dinner party lasted an
hour and a half and you monopolized
sixty minutes of the conversation right
you talked for 60 of the 90 minutes the
other eleven people divided up the
remaining thirty minutes most people who
have sort of normal social awareness
recognize that that's not good behavior
that's not the type of behavior that
that makes sense and I don't know if
Peterson was nervous because of Donald
Trump Jr's presence or because of
kimberly guilfoyle is piercing stare or
whatever but this is just not the way
someone behaves who just has a even
basic understanding of social
interactions well it's another thing if
everyone else is into it like you're the
center of attention and everyone else is
just so taken by your words that's not
the impression that I got especially not
after seeing Charlie Kirk's face and
Donald Trump Jr's face no by no means
send me your thoughts if you if you were
listening to the podcast or on the radio
and you didn't watch that watch it and
then let me know your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show last new
episode of 2018 today one of the day's
sponsors is privacy comm slash Pakman
which is a free service that I might
self use really useful in many different
ways takes just a few seconds to link
your debit card to privacy calm then you
can create virtual credit cards that are
linked directly to your bank account and
you use those virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the Internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a david
pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link